probablemente hablar de revista de
prensa en directo américa de france24
rosa pérez más conmigo en el estudio
rosa vamos a abrir entonces esta revista
de prensa con the gardian indignación
por la convención de la asociación
nacional del rifle en houston sólo dos
días después de la masacre en la escuela
de texas no rosa buenos días raúl
exactamente no the gardian señala esta
casualidad si es que existen o las
casualidades en esta vida y es un poco
pues esta situación perversa y es que
pues como decías sólo pocos días después
tres días después de este tiroteo masivo
en esta escuela de balde en texas no
donde el atacante identificado como
salvador ramos mató a 19 niños haya dos
profesoras pues se celebra en el mismo
estado pero en este caso en la ciudad de
houston pues la convención anual de la
asociación nacional del rifle no el
mayor lobby armamentístico de eeuu y the
gardian nos da el siguiente dato y es
que esta asociación gasta en 2021 5
millones de dólares para presionar a los
legisladores para que se opongan a
medidas como la verificación universal
de antecedentes o a la prohibición de
las armas de asalto y pues se espera en
esta convención aparte de la presencia
de destacados políticos sobre todo
republicanos como donald trump el
senador ted cruz o el gobernador después
del estado de texas greg abbott se
espera que asistan unos 55 mil miembros
de la asociación así como pues protestas
de asociaciones como de padres de
víctimas de tiroteos en escuelas o de
blacklight matters por ejemplo rosa
continuamos lanzando el poder de la nba
por sus siglas en inglés con la posición
de los políticos en texas respecto a
esta legislación sobre las armas no con
una información del medio locales
hablamos del texas frank con los
políticos de texas compartieron su error
y pésame con ubaldo aquí está en cuánto
dinero recibieron de la nr a la
asociación nacional del rifle se titula
ese artículo rosa exactamente dos
periodistas banks y rannikko lo que
dicen es que después de cada tiroteo
masivo los políticos pues expresan su
dolor y su pésame con un guión un poco
prefabricado no hablan del mal invocan a
dios y dicen que sus oraciones y
pensamientos están con las víctimas sin
embargo muchos de estos políticos
después después continúan recibiendo
donaciones de la nba entre otras
asociaciones pro armas y continúan como
decíamos votando en contra de una mayor
regulación de las armas a nivel federal
oa nivel estatal y particularmente estas
dos periodistas contraponen las palabras
de 25 políticos después de la masacre de
la escuela de ubaldo con los dólares que
reciben particularmente de la asociación
nacional del rifle y pues vemos que
comparándolo un poco con estos dólares
que reciben sus palabras parecen un poco
cínica si vamos con las del senador para
texas john cornyn que dijo mi corazón
está con las personas en el hospital que
reciben atención y con los seres
queridos de quienes perdieron la vida
como padre no puedo imaginar el dolor
que deben estar sintiendo y
particularmente john cornyn este senador
ha recibido más de medio millón de
dólares de la era de la asociación
nacional del rifle
583 mil dólares particularmente por otro
lado sessions también miembro de la
cámara de representantes por texas dijo
karen y yo estamos orando por los niños
las familias y la comunidad después de
la tragedia de hoy en ubalde estoy
desconsolado por la pérdida de vidas y
afligido por esta violencia sin sentido
cuantos miles de dólares ha recibido
204 mil también a greg abbott quien ha
recibido en 16 mil dólares más de 16 mil
dólares de la nba o ted cruz el senador
también ha republicano por texas que ha
recibido
176 mil 284 mil dólares y dijo heidi yo
estamos orando por toda la comunidad de
balde en este momento lamentamos las
vidas que fueron arrebatadas por este
acto que cubre maldad hemos visto
demasiados tiroteos ningún padre debería
que soportar el dolor de enterrar a su
hijo y precisamente no sabiendo este
dinero que recibió se entiende más la
situación que vamos a ver en este
momento cuando un periodista de sky news
preguntó al senador republicano ted cruz
por la regulación de armas cuando se
encontraba precisamente de visita a oval
de digamos comunicando expresando su
dolor también con a los padres de los
niños fallecidos
ese es el momento de reformar las leyes
sobre las armas sabe que es fácil entrar
en política pero es importante es el
centro de la cuestión es como los medios
de comunicación quieren tratarlo es lo
que quiere la mayoría de la gente con la
que hemos hablado aquí las propuestas de
los demócratas y de los medios de
comunicación inevitablemente cuando
algún psicópata violento asesina a gente
un psicópata violento se puede conseguir
armas demasiado fácil un chico de 18
años con dos ar-15 si quieres detener el
crimen violento las propuestas que
tienen los demócratas no habrían
impedido esto pero porque esto sólo
sucede en su país realmente creo que eso
es lo que piensa mucha gente alrededor
del mundo porque solo en eeuu porque esa
excepción estadounidense tan horrible
sabes que lo siento si crees que la
excepcionalidad de estadounidense es
horrible creo que ese aspecto es
horrible mira tienes tu agenda política
que dios te bendiga nuevo senador solo
quiero entender por qué no cree que las
armas son el problema
bien a raúl y terminamos con esta viñeta
def la vita banana que ironiza un poco
sobre la posición de muchos políticos
que se oponen a una mayor regulación de
armas porque un poco su argumento
siempre es que las armas no matan solo o
no que son a las personas las que
disparan por eso dice el problema es el
músculo flexor profundo eso hace que el
músculo presione el gatillo por una
américa libre de músculos no es evidente
ridículamente evidente que las armas no
se disparan solas pero también es
evidente que un mayor acceso más fácil
acceso a las armas también favorecen
pues a la violencia armada de hecho eeuu
es de largo el país rico con una mayor
tasa de homicidios por violencia con
armas de fuego
rosas gracias como siempre por esta
revista de prensa nos vemos el lunes con
más información pasamos a saludar a
nuestro primer invitado el día para
hablar precisamente este tema